contrary to popular belief CrossFit is
not a call a little call desk maybe but
definitely not a cult call
ish unlike in a call to in CrossFit you
don't always talk about CrossFit and try
and recruit new members actually come to
think of it
people in CrossFit only talk about
CrossFit and a call you have to give
them tons your money not in CrossFit I
mean the memberships are like $200 a
month but that's for like cleaning and
stuff are we sure it's not a call plus
an occult they make you drink kool-aid
you don't have to drink anything
CrossFit I mean they are always pushing
their protein drinks I joined a cult
didn't I dammit I knew I knew this phone
call it like you recruit new members you
get $10 off the month whoa gee that's a
remember ship for a month
CrossFit isn't actually a call but it is
an annoying human race become so
incredibly lazy
that a regular old gym membership can't
even begin to put a dent in the dietary
destruction we put our bodies through
thanks to modern technology we now have
the attention span of toddlers on speed
need to pay people absurd amounts of
money every month to scream at us to get
in shape which I'm completely okay with
I just wish people in CrossFit weren't
so in-your-face about it and stop asking
me if I signed up for the open whatever
the hell that is
I assume it's something that cuts into
my weekend and forces me to hang out
with everyone from the gym times 10
probably cost money no I didn't sign out
much like my co-workers the last thing I
want to do is spend my free time with
you people
make no mistake I'm not here to make
friends hell I'm not even here to get
healthy
this is strictly a vanity play I'm gonna
look better in my Instagram photos like
every other person at this gym and those
who stayed otherwise are [ __ ] liars
well I'd like to increase mobility
[ __ ] it's also probably a good time
to inform you that I don't care about
your leaderboard either not gonna do an
uncomfortable amount of weight and
injure myself just something that my
name next to an arbitrary number that
means nothing to me as soon as I walk
out the door the subject comes up later
in the day I'll just do what I always do
and lie yeah clean jerk like 275 this
morning and lastly your Paleo diet the
idea of eating what a caveman would have
eaten isn't appealing at all you just
woke am elevating and you know what
cavemen definitely never ate almond
flour pancakes and kale chips I don't
care that you eat like that just stop
making such a big
deal out of it when Deborah brings her
cookies into the office why can't eat
any they're not paleo I'm all for
healthy living habits and physical
well-being just please shut the [ __ ] up
about it thanks for watching be sure to
follow on social and subscribe check out
more episodes text messages used to have
a 160 character limit and cost about 50
cents to send so you couldn't just
blather on about whatever random and
completely unimportant thing you're
thinking about at that very moment
[Music]